Everyday things happen that changed the way the world looks most days
It changes in subtle ways that go unnoticed on other days on more rare days things happen that change it in dramatic
Noticeable ways changes that turn the world upside down and make it so the world of yesterday doesn't even recognize the world of today
On June 2nd, 1993 a girl named Kristy Liana was born she was born to a fairly typical middle-class American family
But she was anything but fairly typical
Almost immediately Kristi showed signs of uniqueness and high intelligence before age one
She was able to form sentences and solve difficult problems on her own at three months old
She figured out how to open the baby-proof latch on her crib and move freely around the house when no one was paying attention
Surprising her father one night when he found her in the living room watching TV on her own
Kristi's parents quickly realized how special she was and knew she would grow up to do something incredible
They told little Kristi that she was going to grow up and change the world as Kristi grew older and started school
She was almost immediately treated differently by her peers and teachers as they found her intelligence to be intimidating and freakish starting in kindergarten
she outgrew almost every grade in every school practically as soon as she started her teachers would tell her how incredible she was and that
She was destined to change the world and that she was too smart for their classroom and perhaps their grade in general
Kristi would end up jumping around to a couple different schools until she finally found a program that could handle her intellect
once situated in a school for gifted children like herself
She would carry out her education and obtain incredible achievements as Kristi flew through elementary school into high school and in college
She would graduate each stage of education multiple years ahead of the norm
Acquiring an Ivy League undergraduate degree by 15 years old and a master's degree in computer science by 17 throughout her education
She would do profound things far ahead of her age and was requested to appear on national TV several times for her accomplishments
It was inevitable to everyone that she would go on and do something incredible and changed the world while she was receiving her master's degree
Kristi's father was diagnosed with stage 4 lung cancer over the several months following the
Diagnosis Kristi watch her father wither down in pain. She had never felt so helpless and tormented she wanted to help her father
She began to research and talk with professors in a desperate attempt to see if there was anything she could do in the small window
Of time she had her father died
not long after the diagnosis long before
he could do anything the pain she felt from her father's death would inevitably change the course of her future the course of
Everyone's future the cancer research and efforts
She made during her father's final months would ignite her career guiding her decisions for how she would attempt to in fact change the world
She realized in this experience of pain and more importantly the pain she witnessed her father experienced
She would do everything in her power to rid the world of such pain to rid the world of disease
Early death and suffering all together to create a world. That's an ideal utopic version of itself
She believed there was a future where this could exist
Having left her mark on so many important members of the Ivy League community during her time in school as well as receiving substantial
awards and achievements
Christie was sought out by leading research tech and software companies
Following graduation she went on to work for several companies in the medical sector and she soon found herself
pursuing research and software development in the genetic engineering space
specifically in terms of removing viruses from patients with existing DNA sequence mutations as well as encoding newborns with genes to have
immunities to major diseases at this time in history
This space was the next big wave in medical research and technology
Researchers and companies were racing to make the next big discovery and find safe predictable ways to edit genetic code and altered people's biology's
However, at the time christie only had so much control over the decision-making in the company
she worked with and felt that decisions were often made poorly and money and focus were often put on the wrong things and so in
Her late 20s christie decided she would start her own medical software company several years later at age 32 in the year 2025
Christy and her company would develop software that could assist in safe highly predictable genetic engineering
Christy would be responsible for creating an algorithm driven simulation
software that could accurately model test and predict the effects of specific DNA editing and
Specific individuals what had previously been highly risky and complicated was now fully accessible
Genetic information could be mapped with extreme detail and the effects of genetic modifications could be accurately
Predicted holistically generations into the future ensuring that manipulations could be executed properly and safely
With this genetic engineering could begin to permeate commonplace medical practice
disease treatment and human childbearing in a short time following cancer and many other
major diseases would be eradicated newborns would be encoded in ways so that all dispositions to physical ailments disabilities and diseases would be
Eliminated as well as all dispositions to mental disorders following that genetic engineering would begin to eliminate
Dispositions towards things like high-level violence aggression depression and anxiety during this time
There were massive worldwide debates regarding the regulations on what should be allowed to be manipulated
But with Kristy's technology
Agreements and systems could be made much more efficiently and genetic engineering would soon become the norm not too long after the technologies
Implementation christi would be recognized publicly as one of the most intelligent and impactful members of modern humanity and for many of all of history
She was awarded the nobel prize as well as innumerable other awards accolades and social recognitions
She had the brilliance the discipline the virtuous social and moral intention the patience and the successful execution
She dedicated her life to this. She sacrificed her youth her young adulthood and her middle adulthood. She worked non-stop
She had no social life. And now she did it. She changed the world forever
Just how she wanted to just how she was told she was supposed to
Fifty years later the world had gone through about two
Generations with Christie's technology and the world's illness and disease rates were at an all-time low
Mental health was at an all-time high the average lifespan was rapidly increasing people were being born with exceptional talents and physical complexions
Incredible things were happening peace and cooperation were blossoming across the planet in a way humanity had never seen
Christie was witnessing her impact unfold into a perfect utopic world just as she had intended
100 more years and four more generations would go by it's the year
2100 and predicted to continue into the low thousands
Suicide rates are the highest ever in history
Having been encoded with specific traits and skills
People find it increasingly difficult to find any meaning in their lives
Knowing they don't have much of a say in who they are or who they become
Being in good physical shape having high intelligence and achieving success are generally easy and aren't that impressive?
So people feel a void of motivation and doing much of anything
Mostly everyone is diplomatic with each other and conflict is almost inexistent
So the majority of people are fairly bored with nothing to talk about there is very little risk of illness or early death
So no one real cares to appreciate what they have essentially
No one has any form of anxiety OCD a DD high anger sadness or anything alike so much of the arts lose their luster
Life is so perfect
it flatlines and
people are now soaking in this nothingness longer than the human brain has ever been equipped to deal with
Frantic the world begins to crumble and people begin to search for ways to reverse the effects of genetic engineering in her late hundreds now
Christie wonders how this could be how she could have been so wrong how could a perfect world be so imperfect
Christie was one of if not the smartest and most virtuous well intended individuals to ever cross humanity
She dedicated her life to changing the world and making it a better place an ideal utopic version of itself
Where health problems were a thing of the past where pain and suffering were a thing of the past?
Were aging and early death were a thing of the past
And were peace health long life and happiness could be a thing of the present and future
She thought she had done it everyone thought she had done it and in essence she did do it
But here she was witnessing the world collapse back in on itself
and in this moment
She realized what she had missed
even in her success of removing everything that appeared to be
Conflict the best she could really do was create new conflict that nature always had the last say and had a funny way of making
Sure
Things stayed interesting that perhaps no matter what she did or whoever would have inevitably done it after her
Everything was to return to the same fundamental balance of good and bad
conflict and resolution
happiness and suffering
That the world upside down is really the same world just at a different angle in this moment Christie understood
It was not that her efforts were a waste
She was the person for the job and she did what she should have done and she did everything right except one thing
She missed the point
Thank you for watching if we found enjoyment and value in this video, please give it a thumbs up
Share your thoughts in the comments below and if you are not already be sure to subscribe to our channel
we are constantly coming out with new videos to help you experience life with clarity and
Wonder